il y a une banane sur la c'est normal
voilà ce qu'il peut arriver de mieux
quand vous êtes journaliste au Kenya une
caresse de bon matin vous êtes en plein
reportage quand tout d'un coup un
éléphant vient vous poser la trompe sur
la tête voilà se faire coiffer par la
trompe quand on est journaliste kenyan
on ne peut pas rester sérieux dans ces
cas-là et même lui et même lui a dû
arrêter son direct la Belgique frappe un
grand coup de com à quelques jours de la
Coupe du monde de football dans un clip
diffusé en ligne par la monarchie le
sélectionneur de l'équipe est reçu par
le roi Philippe et découvre un fan des
Diables rouges qui se verrait bien coach
et c'est Justin
le voilà donc propulsé entraîneur a
donné des consignes aux joueurs
c'est le roi Philippe et franchement il
joue pas mal par rapport à Tsonga dans
les pubs Kinder Bueno franchement il
joue pas alors bon je sais à français
que cette vidéo a vous choqué pour
plusieurs raisons que notre roi y
participe et je comprends que notre roi
soit vivant et en un seul morceau ça je
sais que ça vous surprend toujours et
trois que un francophone parle anglais
ça ça vous déstabilise totalement
sur le bord du terrain Roberto Martinez
Thierry Henry sont conquis un rôle
surprenant pour un roi peu habitué à
casser le protocole
tout souffrance par carte de séjour
je ne sais même pas qui est quart de ces
jours
avec ensemble
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laissez le temps d'insouciance
je t'ai gardé dans mon cœur
dénouement imminent donc pour le
Finistérien dans le calme de la nuit
Guadeloupe merci Pierre-Yves en direct
depuis Pointe-à-Pitre Pointe-à-Pitre
pour l'arrivée de de la Route du Rhum
dans le spectacle vous parlez aussi de
vos infidées vos infidélités
on va rester sur ce sujet là oui oui
par cette alliance je t'aime
il est trop pressé
l'amour c'est comme les pets c'est que
du vent et ça finit toujours par pu à la
fin
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi à la fin seulement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et comme dans tous les cas le club de
vacances il y a des rapprochements c'est
voilà ça se fait et le courant est très
bien passé très très bien passé entre
Joe Biden le président indonésien
[Musique]
ce qu'il se passe à Bali reste à Bali
je fais ça avec mon doigt et je frappe
très très méchant et ça fait du bien ça
fait du bien
[Rires]
famille ensuite on a Yasmine Amir
Sofiane
et ensuite on a les enfants de ma petite
sœur calice et Maïssa je pourrai jamais
tout retenir
en tout ça fait combien donc il y a 12
petits enfants on a gagné
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça
les cheveux de Didier dans un emballage
de pain au lait j'en ai plein je fais
mes courses avec mais non
[Musique]
[Rires]